good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs are
going to solve all of the world's major
problems so to help you on your journey
today we're going to learn how you can
focus on the right people over to you
Trevor Noah well you have to find the
people that are for you you have to
understand whenever you're creating a
product whether it's music whether it's
comedy whether it's TV you're not trying
to make it for everyone you're trying to
find the people that you're trying to
make it for you got to stick to your
truth and then you find those people and
you believe in it so you go is it good
and then I understand I go so so your
lady and her mom are watching and then
even if you're hating on me then I go
find then it's not for you I know you're
not there going there I go yeah you're
not but I have to focus on the people
who are watching me ten times and I'm
going to keep on building on those
people so at the end of the day if you
focus on the people that are trying to
block you you don't you don't spend
enough time enjoying the people that are
celebrating you if you want to have
success then you need to pay careful
attention to the environment that you
have around for yourself if you are
surrounded by people who are telling you
that you can't do it that you suck that
it's never going to work that you don't
have the skill to the education of the
money or whatever reason you will never
be a success because of all of these
logical practical things if you're
surrounded by those people then guess
what happens nothing happens you don't
walk into the big thing because you're
conscious rounded by negativity it's why
so many people just are the average of
their five friends right so look at who
your five friends are and you you want
to be like that or not now doesn't mean
that you have to completely cut them off
it doesn't mean that you need to you
know shun your family but you need to
start creating a more supportive
environment for yourself maybe sane but
Evan I don't know any more successful
people I don't know how to break free
I'm in a crappy area and everybody
around we tells me that I suck and I I
don't know who else to go and turn to
this is the first of your many
challenges that you will come across as
an entrepreneur it's always going to be
about creatively solving problems it's
about how resourceful you can be instead
of how many reads
so you have so here's the first
challenge I don't know any successful
people what am I going to go out and do
Who am I going to turn to for advice the
first person I turn to advice in my
business was my banker I didn't know
anybody I had no connection nobody my
family was an entrepreneur I didn't know
who to talk to so I went to my banker
and I said hi I'm Evan I have a business
bank account with you I'd love to know
how you might be able to help my
business any ideas you have to be
fantastic I said well do you need a loan
or do you need financing like I I don't
know maybe I don't so I'm trying to
figure it out I'm just starting to
figure out what I'm doing to my company
I love your advice and input it's like
well that's not what we do as a bank you
know we give up loans
I thought banks for Leo the Friends of
entrepreneurs so this is how naive I was
right and this is how little knowledge I
had and how few connections I had that I
went to my banker you know but one
conversation leads to another
conversation it's another conversation
and another conversation you're not
going to get the supportive environment
by just sitting on your couch right you
got to go and start talking to people
and connecting and understanding asking
for help
people love the help but the risk is
you're not going to do any work if you
come to me and you ask me for help I'm
jaded because of all the people who've
asked you for help and I give them
advice and they did nothing with so
you're immediately lumped in with those
people so what you want to do is ask for
just a tiny bit of time answer one
little bit of advice and promise and
show your hustle promise that you're
going to do the work on it and then when
you get the advice do the work and then
come back and said listen I took I took
that advice don't going to ask our
mentor you don't want to commit to a
relationship with you one bit of advice
they used two fingers there one bit of
advice want to change and then go and do
the work and come back and say listen I
did this work and it worked or didn't
work I tried and I did hours and hours
and hours and it didn't work out I don't
make it better if they see that you're
taking the initiative and actually
executing now you start to send out
there's other ways to be strong right
people though - it's not just mentorship
join a meetup group connect with online
communities we have a number we have an
awesome online community here and
believe nation where people are
supporting each other and try to help
each other with the business join other
online groups learn from virtual mentors
one of the things that helped me the
most in me thinking bigger and wanted to
play on a different level I'm thinking I
could do more and really feeling like I
could have a big impact on this world
one of the things that helped me most
was my own youtube channel it's selfish
for me that I'm sharing it with you it's
a selfish endeavor for me that I share
with you guys and I'm so grateful and so
happy that you enjoy too when I'm around
constantly Elon Musk and Steve Jobs and
Oprah Winfrey and all these people who
have done amazing things are still
pushing to try to be better
what I'm in that environment I want to
do bigger things I want to have a much
bigger impact so the more around that
the more it shifts my focus is just my
attention and makes me feel like I can
contribute more and it builds a new
environment for myself if you want to do
great things you need to create an
environment of greatness otherwise it's
never going to work so the question
today today is I'm curious what kind of
people do you have in your life and are
they the right people to help you get to
where you need to go what changes are
you going to make after watching this
video I'm curious leave it down the
comments below super curious to find out
I also want to give a quick shout out to
Dave Gardner from the Dave Gardner com
they take you so much you're picking up
a cup of my book your one word doing
review taking a picture I really really
appreciate it man
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the
book so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events presto
or expresso keep me go
you're happy with it though I'm real
happy here you know when I see this
thing play in front of an audience
people go crazy what is the run those
Inside the Actors Studio question so
what's your process once you want you do
this you want to watch it with other
audiences you don't want to see it don't
study this thing what's your process
wants you once they say cut you know you
can't cut it up you know you got to
watch with an audience it's not drama
right rubber is whatever you want it to
be when you when you make drama you are
like Picasso and just like okay whatever
when you make comedy you're not that
kind of painter you like a painter down
at the promenade
paetynn portraits to people you know you
want more blue and guys I'm a booyah I
think you want to be taller okay power
you know I'm one of those guys right
that's so when you make comedy making
for the people that you know you try to
have as many screenings
there's many tests and you do focus
groups and you read the cards or you try
to try to get the people what they want
in this comedy man people ask me
sometimes I'm you make a movie with an
audience in mind yeah and my answer is
yes I do
all right but the audience I have in
mind isn't some faceless blob that I'm
trying to second-guess it's me I like a
focus group
yeah it's me I'm the audience I'm the
guy that goes out and pays $7 or $8 PPT
part you know to go and see a movie all
right I do so if I'm excited about
seeing a movie I see it on opening day
all right
I am the audience all right and I know
what I want to see you know and I was
betting and I was a little surprised at
how many there were
I was betting that there are other
people like me out there all right now
true I'm making specific films and if
you make a specific film that's not
everything for everybody you're going to
turn some people off all right but
you're going to turn some people on - in
the old day when a Stockton action
movies I just make audience laughing you
know do all the funny things you know I
like oh I just and kick the ball and
I really had that yeah
but slowly slowly from the audience from
the audience from the media especially
from the fans they write a letter or now
I have a baby so say I cannot see the
movie because the dirty work because the
dirty action because this all those
years a change change change change
change
but with all all the dirty things still
can make audience laughing that's a
difficult it's an audience all offense
or the mediate teach me becoming a good
filmmaker